all right trivia time this will
determine the first pick in the goats
draft goats in a bad way draft peter
king gets the question last night peter
was seattle's third win this year when
trailing by 10 or more points name one
of the other two teams they beat while
overcoming a double digit deficit
um
i would say
the
uh
tampa bay buccaneers
peter you win you get the first pick in
the draft and a new car
i mean
i truly hate to pick on this guy
because as i wrote the other day he's
going to be a walk-in hall of famer but
i gotta go with adam vinatieri
the fact that he misses his sixth extra
point of the year which is an absolute
outrage and needs to make frank reich
and chris ballard get off there adam
vinatieri as solid as a rock spot
uh the fact that he missed that
came up
to kill him at the end of the game
because now being down by four instead
of three
you've got your back up quarterback
being forced to score a touchdown
instead of getting getting in field goal
position which i wouldn't trust vina
terry now anyway to get him in field
goal position but anyway i think adam
vinatieri is my biggest goat of the week
yeah that's uh that's a good one i mean
you're right i mean he's awesome guy
first ballot hall of famer if there is
such a thing with a kicker he's
certainly one of the clutches we've ever
seen but it's uh not pretty that's for
sure um i'm gonna actually stay with
this a similar concept but i'm just
going to use the chief's field gold unit
in general i mean the chiefs were lining
up to go up by eight points with under
two minutes left in the football game
and of course i don't know who to blame
whether it's the snapper the holder
either way the ball was snapped and the
holder wasn't ready so you got a chance
there to go up eight and make the
tennessee titans offense which is gonna
have to throw in that moment and had not
really thrown the ball with great
success until the very end and you give
them somewhat of a short field to go and
get a game-winning touchdown okay
patrick mahomes gets the ball back and
damn if he doesn't make some the
damnedest throws once again and gives
them another chance to kick a field goal
to win the football game and of course
they block it off the right edge so the
whole unit for the you know kansas city
chiefs field gold unit uh they are goats
in a bad way
last sunday i rhymed
i'm gonna stick with the theme of
kickers and kicking units and and and
also so influenced by what we saw last
night kudos to chase mclaughlin for
making the 47-yard field goal to force
overtime but then when you get the
opportunity to win it in overtime and
it's not even close
when you adam vinatieri the
try the one it was almost as wide left
as the vinatari kick in pittsburgh
it wasn't it had no chance i mean you're
a professional kicker and i understand
you just got thrust into the job but
you've got to at least make it close in
that spot this is your opportunity to
write your ticket for the next five
years in the nfl if you can show that
you can make a big kick in overtime and
i mean you make the one to save the game
and the overtime right and then and then
to just oh look at that it's like it got
blocked and it didn't
so sorry chase welcome to the nfl
congratulations on the kick you made you
should have made the other one i just
don't like that we called them out for
being like no i don't like the like the
people say oh the pressure got to him
well the pressure didn't get to him at
the end of regulation i mean yeah he
missed that one and that was bad but
just we can't say he choked after he
just made a clutch one to tie the game
at the end of regulation it was just a
damn really ugly crappy kick
my next is gonna be jimmy garoppolo and
it's not for any one play it's for a
body of work playing with happy feet
throwing balls
at vital times a game of the game that
aren't close to being completed throwing
a ball at a huge point in the game right
off kj wright's hands i it's just it's
not acceptable it's not good enough
and again it's a cruel business
sometimes but the reason the 49ers lost
that game last night is jimmy garoppolo
yeah it certainly didn't give 49ers fans
or me any confidence to sit there and go
oh gosh yep jimmy garoppolo he we can we
can trust them at all the big moments no
it was shaky in a lot of ways whether it
was not paying attention to the pass
rush around them or just some of the
errant throws we saw in general uh there
was issues there altogether i'm going to
stay with another quarterback that we
saw in prime time this week and that was
the guy on thursday night phillip rivers
you know they're the chargers
that's a double win when i got a good
one and i stole his yes uh but yeah you
know hey the chargers fighting back you
know again oh here we go they got a
chance to get back in the playoff race
and and really uh you know have a chance
as far as just reasserting themselves
into the conversation and he laid an egg
on thursday night you know they ran the
ball well they hadn't seen a lot of that
this year so melvin gordon's good but
the interceptions and some big moments
uh especially and if i remember
correctly even had one called back
because of a penalty just too careless
with the football just disappointing for
a guy like phillip rivers who's done so
many great things over the years to that
organization
thursday night was not one of his best
nights i mean he's oh it's a wide open
receiver on the first drive where you go
man if they can get oakland in the hole
here early and build some confidence
watch out uh you know the receiver slips
on the second one okay yes well you know
when when you have a weak arm and you
have to throw the ball you know four
steps before the guy comes out of the
break you know that's what happens
sometimes okay and then here's the one
in the end zone that was huge as well so
that was not good and i believe that was
the one that was called back actually
the thing about philip rivers that
throwing motion is so funky when the
ball is accurate you don't really notice
it when the ball is grossly inaccurate
it is the worst throwing motion you have
ever seen in your entire life all right
i i'm going to stick with the prime time
theme i'm going to go to sunday night
and i'm going to give the goat horns to
jason garrett because when you're moving
the ball down the field and the vikings
aren't even playing defense dak prescott
is throwing it and throwing it and
throwing it on first and 10 from the 19.
he throws it eight yards sets it up
second and short at the 11. and it's
just inevitable they're going to score
the touchdown and then the vikings are
going to gack on the on the ensuing
drive and the cowboys are going to win
the game and they call a running play on
second down
and then they call a running play on
third down the cowboys weren't able to
run
on sunday night and they definitely were
able to run in that spot and after
ezekiel gets bottled up in second down
why in the hell are you doing it again
on third down here's the sequence if
you're watching on tv it was to cooper
on first down everything's still going
great then ezekiel goes nowhere on
second down and then comes the third
down play where they just he doesn't
even have a chance
so they have to go for it on fourth down
eric kendricks makes a great play on the
ball to knock it away a great coverage
linebacker and that's it game over
almost the vikings still had to sweat
out of hail mary but jason garrett what
are you doing with the play calls there
you got to keep throwing the ball dak
prescott was spectacular and i'm not
gonna get extra cynical and say you
don't want dak prescott to deliver that
huge victory because then it's gonna
cost you more to keep him i don't think
they care about that
but the guy was having a great night
he's had one of the best nights of his
career and you take the ball out of his
hands on those two plays i don't get it
jason garrett gets it
[Music]
stop it
stop it bullwinkle go ahead my third
my my third one is going to be the los
angeles rams offense i don't know
who to give the goat horns to and this
is a collective award
uh that not only it isn't only from the
steelers game i probably would if i had
to give it to one group it'd be the
offensive line but
you know golf has been just a pedestrian
player all year
uh you know where the heck is the
running game that used to be dominant i
mean i have no idea i've never seen a
running back fall off a cliff the way
todd gurley has i i wish we could just
get the truth about him and maybe the
truth is uh they're just not blocking
for it anymore and so i i was thinking
for a while of doing the giants
offensive line you know because saquon
barkley rushed for 2.7 inches per carry
on sunday but i'm gonna give it to a
team that
must be playing better and should be
playing better and that's the offensive
unit of the rams yeah damn you stole
mine peter you jerk okay who invited you
on this show anyways all right why don't
you take jerome boger the guy who called
the aaron rodgers roughing call i almost
died
they won the game so we couldn't do it
yeah that was horrible you're right but
i mean i i was going to give it to
mcveigh and goff i really was mcveigh's
got to reinvent himself he's not they're
not the only team in football that's got
offensive line issues they got a figure
and some of those plays we showed right
there the pass protection was fine for
jared goff they were just bad throws and
you're you know again i don't like to
sit here and bag on guys but when you're
being paid 35 million dollars a year
you're allowed to open pandora's box for
criticism i'm just sorry that's just the
way it's reality of football
i'm gonna go with kyle allen of the
carolina panthers and man i don't like
to do this either because he did some
good things in the game
uh on on sunday and put them in position
to have a chance to win the game at the
end but also they could have been in a
much better position
earlier on if he doesn't throw a red
zone interception when they drive down
uh in the late late in the third quarter
where he kind of runs up in the pocket
throws a pick in the back in the end
zone and fumbling a snap at midfield at
one point that led to a short field
touchdown by the green bay packers i
believe it was in the second quarter at
that point when that happened you know
those were just two big moments of the
game where
it was two teams kind of going toe to
toe and really felt like carolina had
found their footing and was kind of out
playing green bay and you know between
the interception and the fumble those
were points that were left uh or left on
the board or didn't get on the board or
uh gave gave green bay points and they
were big moments for me
yeah last one for me and this is a guy
who specifically went to the coach last
week and said i want to have a bigger
role on the team and his quote was you
want to be that player that your team
wants you to be and that's colt's tight
end eric ebron well eric if you're going
to be that guy one important thing to
keep in mind when it's fourth and 10
with the game on the line you got to run
your route to the sticks it ain't that
hard the yellow line's not on the field
but the sticks are on the field you have
to run your route to where the first
down is or given the whole nature of
four downs the game's gonna be over and
that was you know we could we can pick
on adam terry for the missed extra point
and we should because a field goal in
that spot would have forced overtime if
everything else played out the same way
but eben in that spot you can't run a
nine yard route you've got to run a
10-yard route on fourth down and 10 it's
that simple and he just didn't get deep
enough and that's on him guy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports